Actually, give me one second... I wanna open the door a little wider
M: Hey
M: How's it going?
M: Welcome to in bed with Markiplier
*kiss*
Give me a clap
*clap*
Gave me the clap...
*weird noises from Mark* Alright...
M: *makes frightened noise*
M: *thud*
M: AHH-HOW
You're like, three shots in, man!
Perfect
Cut *laughing*
Bye *laughing*
Can we hit the other bottles this time?
*crashing noises*
*laughing*
Perfect *laughing*
One more that's a little more natural? *laughter*
M: Pretty natural, I don't know about you
I mean, you got them all
Yeah, you got to do that again, I suck
*laughing*
*heavy breathing*
M: THEY'RE COMMING TO GET ME
M: SWAG *laughs*
M: WHAA, OOH, UGH *more grunting*
M: Not today, not today!
sh*
f*
M: Ow.
Not gonna lie, dude...
...it's a lot more fun than I thought it would be
M: Discovering some fettishes here
I'm finding out a lot about myself
I'd be careful with that knife!
as for, uhh I hit my elbow
*laughter*
I'd be careful with that knife!
M: Uh, a horrible gruesome death?
M: Uh, 25 years of life with a cellmna- mne-nay-name
M: F*
M: I almost had that
Flashing some gang signs...
Yes, yes, we're rolling
M: Flashing some gain signs... ;)
Lying to the poli- ugh.
*laughing*
(sarcastically) Lying to the police would be pretty cool
Let's try again
Well I don't know, lying...
Pff, jesus, I really want him to lie
(music playing) "...Am I going mad?"
"One mistake's all it takes, and this may go bad"
"No one's there... no one's there..."
Glad I was rolling on that
M: Oh, you were?
"Is it true? Are they back? Am I going mad?"
*loud breathing*
*laughter*
*laughing* You all right?
M: NO, KEEP GOING!
M: *laughing* No one's there... no one's...
Here we go
(music playing) "...focus on me! Somethings-"
M:  ...breathing out beyond the door *laughing*
M: That's what I do when I'm nervous, I just whip my dick out
M: *singing* Something's breathing out beyond the door...
M: *heavy breathing*
M: *singing* Why's my closet making pirate sounds?
M: HOOCHAA
M: *singing* Why's my closet making haha, goddammit
M: *laughing* I was too focused on the movements
M: I was gonna do like the... l was gonna do everything, like the
West Side Story...
M: *singing* Why's my closet making pirate sounds *laughing*
M: *laughing* I was trying to do the whip and the nae nae while I was walking
*laughing* It's like, are you one of the animatronics
*laughing* Like, are you supposed to have a puppet on your head?
M: *laughing* Just dab the whole way, just "WHY'S MY CLOSET-"
M: WHAA HAAA
M: Oh, sorry
*laughter*
OW
M: *sensual* Hey, thanks for watching,
remember to subscribe to this channel
and as well as the other channel that was also involved
I don't know where this one is...
*inhale*
cool...
*smeck*
M: This isn't sexy, is it...
*laughter* No
M: Not at all
*laughter*